you know Tom and feel kind of have
matching outfits they wanted you know if
I'd want to wear black and red like
tiger I'm like I'm not wearing black and
red that's Georgia Bulldog colors I mean
I just can't do that I mean it you want
me to get six on the first hole I'll do
it but you know I'm not gonna let Kirby
Smart get a picture of me and black and
red for their social media accounts my
partner's gonna make this right here
these aren't the Falcons are playing
against Tigers a pretty good closer same
colors though it's the Eagles that I
cringe bro not the Falcons we step on
that pretty machine
they haven't been good since you left
you helped reduct remember bottom Porter
backs ISM Berkeley and Thomas are in
trouble so I was talking to Tom about
you know you guys stay loose when you're
playing golf and one of the ways that he
has stayed loose during his football
career is by playing some practical
jokes but Tom your good buddy Sam Reeves
told me someone else got you good and it
resulted in you having purple feet for
about three weeks so do you want to tell
us that story oh that's a pretty good
story yeah when I was a rookie we had a
lot of rookie pranks and got out to
practice one day actually we had this
loop where we put our laundry after
practice and so it's watched for the
next day and when I got my loop the next
day there were no socks in it so I went
to the club manager I said I need new
socks and so he gave me a pair of socks
and unbeknownst to me drew bledsoe had
put this purple dye that was like a
powder in my side so I practiced for two
hours and then I looked at it at this
point in practice and the purple started
seeping through the shoe that died and I
said what the hell is going on with my
shoes well I got in the locker room and
I had to peel my socks off of my feet
and I had
this dark purple stain at my feet look
like Barney the Dinosaur for three weeks
and man I scrubbed as hard as I could I
think I scrubbed with Clorox and just
about everything else but I finally got
it off do I want to know what the
revenge prank was you know what I
learned at a young age when people have
a lot more money than you you don't
think back you just accept it and you
move on so fortunately I had a few
rookies too as I got a little bit older
and I had a couple more bucks in them in
their pockets though you run the butt
end of a lot of pranks of mine did you
just add some rain pants or change pants
or I split my pants you got so excited
that you split your pants after making
that well so much torque in that swing
that's I'll tell you what there's one
guy who was enjoying watching these
quarterback struggle and that is a man
who's making himself a legend already
one of the great defenders in the NFL JJ
Watt the pride of Pewaukee Wisconsin
talking to us on WebEx from his home in
Houston great to see you JJ how you
enjoying the match so far thank you for
having me I mean I've been enjoying it
you know it's a chance for us around the
league we don't get to see Tom struggle
too often so today we got a chance to
see it everybody and I was all ready to
come on here and talk about how at the
turn he needs a shot gonna call the
beers that kind of loosen up and then
once he do he drains one from 150 out so
you know JJ number one I want to thank
you for all the charitable stuff you've
done
over the years you've been amazing so
thank you from all four all the players
but let me ask you a question how is
this offseason yes I mean it's obviously
different for everybody but how have you
been able to get with your teammates and
work out doing this quarantine time yeah
Thank You Chuck I appreciate it
it's obviously been a little bit
different we've had virtual media kind
of just like this where we we all meet
on zoom' or whatever do we go over our
place in the playbook and install I
actually in 2011 my first year in the
league was when there was a lockout so
we had no office
Oh TAS we just want to stray into
training camp so it's very similar to
that time and as long as you're training
running working out doing what you have
to do you'll be ready to go now if
you're not you're going to be in serious
bit of trouble especially down here in
Houston in the 110 degree heat comm
training camp I always like to go
scavenger hunt when we do these calls
here JJ I'm guessing those are your
three Defensive Player of the Year
awards behind you or not that you're
showing the brothers what you guys have
your own show going down and you're
doing a lot and I know your connection
with wheels-up is strong and your
charitable influence not just in Houston
but back in Wisconsin as well and kailia
your wife you guys do great work what's
coming up for you JJ what are you
excited about moving forward trying to
get through this time thank you I
appreciate you know it's been such an
honor to work with feeding America and
the other great organizations and wheels
up and to be able to make those
donations to help people out of me we
went through with Hurricane Harvey and
everything and just working with these
organizations and seeing how much time
and effort energy people put in and
seeing so many people help out their
fellow human and tough times I think
that's the thing in situations like this
that gives me the most hope for humanity
is how many people are willing to step
up and help out there for their neighbor
waterin off-the-field JJ thank you for
being with us thank you guys I
appreciate looking forward to the back
JJ Watt from the Houston Texans
wheels-up ambassador Russell Wilson kind
enough to join us here it's we couldn't
have one more quarter back in the mix hi
Russell how are you doing I'm gonna go
with whoever's 12 feet from the hole
whoever's closest to the hole okay
twelve feet with it within 12 feet I'll
give up I can have a hundred thousand
one hundred thousand meals for each one
oh I'm gonna sweeten this pot a little
bit with PD American Meals up and what
we've been doing with wheels up
so let's partner up here
good job Russell that's awesome
appreciate you man here and we're gonna
give it a look here just stay with us
Russell because I got a couple things
ask you here in a minute but awesome
that you could add to that Russell
Wilson and the Seattle Seahawks joining
the quarterback brigade here got a
little time as they get ready to to tee
it off Russell I want to ask you real
quick about the why not you Foundation I
know you guys are doing great things
with Sierra yeah it's been a blessing
you know obviously in the midst of the
storms of what we've been going on with
Cole of it and everything else
Sierra NIDA you know let's be able to
give back and to really make a
difference you know our whole foundation
is based on this idea what my dad used
to always say you know someone not you
and I think that in this in the midst of
storm missile all the things that were
going through you know why not us you
know how about we all make a difference
and and that why not you attitude so
we've been able to raise millions and
millions of dollars of the gears with
childhood cancer and life and everything
else and we were able to do you know a
bunch of meals you know in Seattle and
and with feeding an American with meals
up to as well with wine Hugh found a
Shinzo it's been a blessing to be able
to give back and serve and you know and
you know hopefully you know hopefully
Brady can make this interesting here so
I can't wait to watch this perfect
timing it's on a pretty good line yes
sir is it ever
Wow
yeah for sure inside 12 feet nice going
Russell that was well executed maybe you
and Tom had something worked out prior
to that big shot right there by Tom fun
you know I was telling Thomas he was
slow earlier playing not playing his
best earlier I made fun of them to tell
them told him that me and Sierra versus
Tom and Giselle what weather and Bahamas
are Mexico so Giselle and Sierra chose
Mexico so we're gonna have to have some
fun one of these days I love it
all right Phil down come on just checked
up you're going every shot inside twelve
is a hundred thousand meals well done
two on the floor right now they remember
the twenty five million dollar hole in
one challenge here too
that accurate shot right out of - yeah
good shot good perfect that's a great
shot my baton right there Wow
this is just legendary stuff right here
between these guys man's is so much fun
that's got a good line on it to Wilson
way to go man it is great to see you
thank you you played through this kind
of rain no problem no problem even
mother nature couldn't stay away
everyone wanted to see what the four of
you guys could do today what you did was
raised real money for real change but
let's talk about how fun it was along
the way you two made a big run on that
fact nine what was the teamwork that you
guys really enjoyed today my man hit
some really great shots on this back
nine and we fought hard to make up we I
was a little nervous a little tight the
front nine and my man kept us in there
and the back nine he really shined and
hit some great shots and we made a run
and came really close yeah well Phil
said you had the home course advantage
you also have Payton on your side who
played great Peyton what was this
experience like Phil de said he was
nervous imagine I know Tom and I would
kind of comparing notes and feelings of
each other so you know to go behind the
ropes in these guys world and to kind of
be in the arena with them it was really
a special experience and I was not
comfortable the entire time from the
first tee all the way down here but
knowing that 20 million dollars was
raised and helping people that are
really going through tough times it was
an honor for Tom and I both to be
invited by Phil and Tiger to play in
this match and really something I'll
always remember and cherish in Tiger you
know how much the viewers have been
wanting live golf to bring them that and
be able to do this what does it mean
[Music]
inflected fact that the
we ever hats off to them for coming out
this is our arena this will be big
we could imagine going on the field
do what they do it was so much fun to
watch incredible job congratulations all
four of you Brian they're all legends
and today they were the ultimate
grinders through the rain way to go guys